vous savez que Noël s'en vient dans
quelques jours alors pour les réfugiés
Ukrainiens qui ont fui la guerre dans
leur pays ce sont un premier Noël au
Canada ils sont nombreux ils seraient
plus 132000 mais en fait les demandes
qui ont été faites pour venir
s'installer au Canada ça rend ça monte à
700 000 il y a des demandes qui sont
encore en train de cheminer actuellement
on en reçoit deux jeunes femmes
ukrainiennes qui se sont réfugiés ici
deux sœurs Randa et Gada Gazal alors
Randa c'est vous Gada c'est vous bonjour
à vous deux merci d'être avec nous
racontez-nous un peu comment ça s'est
passé comment vous avez pris la décision
de quitter votre ville qui était dans un
secteur qui était durement affecté par
la guerre comment ça s'est passé cette
décision et donc premièrement on a
quitté notre pays deux semaines avant
que la gare commence car j'étais
enceinte et nous vivons dans base dans
Nicolas en 2014
Poutine a essayé de commencer une petite
gare là-bas donc c'est la deuxième fois
qu'on quitte notre pays oui et quand
j'étais enceinte on dit qu'on va aller à
notre pays pour qu'on voit qu'est-ce
qu'il va se faire et on a quitté après
en deux semaines la gare a commencé et à
4h30 le matin on a reçu l'information
que les bombes descend sur tout notre
pays et on a vu que Canada offre un
logement pour les gens comme nous de
venir et commencer une autre vie une
nouvelle vie ici en tant qu'on attend
qu'est-ce qu'il va se faire en notre
pays donc on a commencé le processus et
on a entendu le visa et le 18 mai on a
pris la décision comme une famille de
venir ici
un Canada et voir qu'est-ce qu'elle peut
nous offrir comme un pays qui a du P
premièrement et tout ça une décision
vous avez pris en famille aussi parce
que vous êtes deux sœurs vous avez aussi
je pense d'autres membres de votre
famille qui sont avec vous qui est venu
avec vous ma mère et mon père
le mari du Randan
nous sommes tous ensemble maintenant
il y a un bébé donc qui est ni ça s'est
bien passé comment s'appelle votre
enfant c'est Milas
je l'ai accouché le 17 juin ici au
Québec en grand bien l'hôpital de Granby
a été une agréable femme que nous avons
rencontré
elle s'appelle Anne-Marie de bois et sa
famille elle a donné son appartement
gratuitement pour deux mois à promo et
elle m'a et avec ses amis Sonia et
Michel et Dominique rock ils m'ont
envoyé chez le médecin il me dit comment
ça se fait ici car le système est un peu
Facom qu'on le sait et il fait tout ce
que le fait doit faire et après j'ai
accouché mon bébé et c'était
splendidement à l'hôpital tous les gens
étaient énormément gentils très donné un
cadeau à moi quand j'ai accouché tout ça
donc vous êtes vraiment accueilli vous
êtes vraiment et comment ça se passe
l'intégration après il faut se trouver
un travail il faut se rebâtir une
nouvelle vie comment ça se passe on a
déjà trouvé du travail
et on travaille
c'était pas difficile et pas facile
encore c'était
excuse vous avez l'avantage de parler
français ce qui est pas sous pas
fréquent chez les gens qui sont réfugiés
ici avec qui on parle comment vous
l'avez appris le français c'était à
l'école
mon père il parle français encore et
c'était décision que nous doit parler la
langue française à l'anglais et
mon père a mis pour nous
enseignants saignante et on a étudié le
français mais on n'a pas pratiqué la
langue français depuis longtemps
ça vous aide quand même ça vous donne
quand même une base
je peux pas imaginer les gens qui
viennent du l'Ukraine ne savent avec une
langue mais l'anglais du français pour
nous c'était très dur et très difficile
pour
commencer une vie d'une longue qui ne
l'a pas pratiqué et c'était un peur de
venir ton quoi c'est pas Canada on sait
rien de si mais la gouvernement a donné
énormément réellement pour les gens qui
ont au Canada récupérer les gens qui
sont restés en Ukraine et encore où on
va Service Canada service Québec tous
ces régions ils nous aide il sait que on
s'abriand dans votre règle et tout ça et
elle prend le temps d'expliquer comment
ça se fait comment étape qu'on doit les
faire et tout ça en ordre le Noël s'en
vient on va montrer des photos de votre
Noël de l'an dernier votre Noël de l'an
dernier c'était chez vous c'était en
Ukraine alors c'était dans un secteur où
vous avez grandi où vous avez des liens
on vous voit ici avec votre famille
comment vous voyez ça passer maintenant
votre premier Noël ici donc à l'étranger
pour vous même si c'est votre nouvelle
demeure est-ce que est-ce que vous vous
sentez nostalgique comment émotion vous
habite actuellement à surement c'est
très nostalgique car on est
habitué d'être avec toute notre famille
et cette fois on est seul seulement la
mini-famille à la grande famille et
c'est tout différent on savait qu'est-ce
qu'on faisait là-bas on faisait du dîner
chez nous et tout ça mais comme je veux
dire que madame Anne-Marie Debois nous a
donné le sapin et un cadeau de Noël elle
a fait réellement notre maison très
gentil et comment les la transmosphère
du Noël et un peu revenu oui est-ce que
vous gardez des contacts avec des gens
en Ukraine est-ce que vous téléphonez ou
avec les ordinateurs grâce à Skype ou
les autres moyens vous avez des contacts
réguliers sur chaque jour en téléphone
chaque jour donc vous suivez aussi
l'actualité vous savez bien sûr comment
vous vivez ce comment on vit la guerre
de loin quand on a des gens qu'on aime
qui sont restés là-bas c'est trop
difficile de réveiller chaque jour que
tu ne se voit pas si ton maison et
encore là-bas ou ta famille est vie ou
non c'est trop difficile pour nous c'est
on vit ça chaque jour
est-ce que vous pleurez parfois ensemble
en chaque jour
vous êtes quand même la chance d'être un
groupe de pas être une personne seule
parce qu'il y a des réfugiés qui sont
arrivés seuls qui ont pas de groupe de
sport est-ce que c'est une communauté où
les gens se parlent beaucoup est-ce que
vous êtes en lien avec d'autres
personnes comme vous mais qui sont plus
isolées oui oui sur le facebook elle
vient beaucoup d'équipes de surtout si
pour moi Réal pour les aides uriniens à
Montréal donc on communique toujours ces
quelqu’un besoin du
lad ou quelque chose nous sommes ici
pour aider tout vous êtes très solidaire
finalement comment vous avez vécu cette
tragédie nous sommes tellement
bouleversé de cette petite fille de 7
ans Maria qui a été frappée par une
voiture ça c'est funérailles ce matin
tout le Québec était bouleversé on
voulait accueillir cet enfant-là pour
qu'elle ait une vie meilleure et
finalement elle est décédée comment dans
la communauté ukrainienne on a vécu ça
donc je crois que tous les gens sont
très choqués parce que c'est passé car
comme vous avez dit
et après être comme ça c'est terminé sa
vie c'était choquement pour la mer et on
a rien de dire seulement que on espère
que la maman va être mieux mais comment
être mieux après sa tragédie alors on
sait que le papa est venu l'argent
rejoindre maintenant donc c'est une
famille qui essaie de survivre mais qui
a d'autres enfants dans l'actualité ce
qui a été très marquant et c'est ce dont
on a parlé tout au long des missions
c'est la présence de votre Président
Monsieur Zelinski qui est actuellement
aux États-Unis on l'a vu aux côtés de
Joe Biden monsieur Biden qui a répété
qu'il allait donner son appui à
l'Ukraine comment vous vivez ça de le
voir votre président côté de jordiden
aujourd'hui
c'est un de ces temps plaisir de voir
Monsieur
zilenska avec Monsieur Brighton
on espère que seulement que ça te garde
va terminer
un espoir que tout va être bien pour
tous les ukrainiens et notre famille et
nos amis et tout
et vous je suis tellement fière de voir
un homme comme Monsieur Zolan ski qui
parle avec tous les gens il veut
n'importe qui pour aider l'Ukraine il
fait tout il va tout et c'est très fier
quand je vois
notre président
quand ils battent où il est comme
exemple en deux jours avant il était à
baroute il y a tout qui descend et il
est avec son armée là-bas c'est très
très joli de voir ça comme il est
courage alors vous avez une grande
fierté finalement une grande fierté
d'être présentée par cet homme très
courageux et vous savez que pour nous
vous êtes aussi une source d'inspiration
parce que vous êtes des gens extrêmement
fort
résilient déterminer mais ce qu'on vous
souhaite du fond du coeur c'est un
joyeux premier Noël dans notre province
dans notre pays malgré toutes les
épreuves malgré toute la nostalgie la
peine parfois mais soyez vraiment assuré
quand vous souhaite le meilleur Noël
possible et une belle vie ici est-ce que
vous pensez peut-être retourner en
Ukraine après quand la gare terminée oui
on va retourner pour célébrer pour
célébrer
alors merci à vous deux merci d'avoir
été merci beaucoup